behind the scenes of carly rae jepsen
new music video hi friends it is Friday
that means it's got me feeling a certain
kind of way but I'm going to blame my
good mood on carly rae jepsen her song
cut to the feeling is the catchy summer
jam that i have literally been singing
in the shower since it dropped carly rae
shot the video for the song and my girl
Sophia Lacey scored a special invite to
the set
how do right here on the set of your new
music video came out the promised for
the video today
very casual Sun jivey silly a rehearsal
day you're getting to see us actually
with my fake band as well my real band
boys couldn't make it down so it it's
all my friends Oh
the farm also featured in Elle family's
new animated building Canyon starts at 5
a.m. we push to after lunch now you're
also lending your voice to a character
yeah it was really fun I shot in
Montreal in the middle of kind of the
tour there and it was very much like a
video game because all over the
characters are already clapping in
motion it took me probably about an hour
to to get the service now the 31 year
old getting into the flow writing a new
album her first since 2015 that album
she wrote more than 150 songs 12 made
the cut this time around she's already
spend around please
called it experimental what exactly does
that mean well I don't want experimental
aizen like experimental jazz or into
some like new weird mode no it's at a
place where I'm really open to not
really having to define what I'm making
IDs that I call it like so to clean your
house shoes
I got to say it is good to be carly rae
jepsen right now
it was just announced that she will open
for Katy Perry on the witness tour which
will now kick off on September 19th and
cut to the feeling by the way is also
the theme song for MTV's new reality
series yes the key and the full video is
expected to drop next week so go ghetto
girl all right now turning to Carly
Ray's pal Justin Bieber it's been nearly
a month since he canceled his world tour
but thankfully for all US believers he
has dropped some new music the track is
called friends and is a collab with
blood pop and I gotta say I'm feeling it
take a listen
can't we be sure
[Music]
[Applause]
can we be said
isn't that fire now based on the lyrics
you can't help but think Justin wants
things to get back to normal the song is
definitely about a breakup but is it
about his ex Selena Gomez well many fans
seem to think so they were of course on
and off for five years and with lyrics
like though we didn't end this all good
but you know we had something so good so
I'm wondering can we still be friends it
seems like he could be reaching out
swing has been with the weekend since
January and in this song Justin says
he's been recently calling someone who
may have moved on well one thing's for
sure this song is a jammer and after two
years of headline-making antics since
purpose it's just the kind of attention
Justin needs right now
now Justin's new bop is just one of many
new music Friday jams we got for you
today we've got more tracks for you and
just a few but first what do you think
of my Julie Chen impression but first
like your thing alright it's time to
talk about Big Brother the show is in
its 19th season and is as addicting as
ever last night with the season's first
double eviction but more on that please
welcome my bomber jacket brother Brice
and etc that's a big brother than get it
right you just caught up with our pal
your BFF Julie how's her chin blonde
she's a queen as always a true queen and
like you said last night first double
eviction two houseguests are gone and
Julie had a lot of thoughts about it
here's what you had to say about where
the game goes from here season 19 first
double eviction your reaction to Cody
and Elena out of the house well Cody was
dead man walking you knew it I knew it
he knew it everybody knew it but it's
frustrating because I know that a lot of
the viewers like Cody and if they
already like him based on what they saw
which was kind of a hothead right if he
had just shown a human face earlier and
throughout the game he kind of lasted I
think he wanted to get evicted and it's
not he would have self inflicted with
Elena Wow you know right now mark and
Elena they did not have the numbers on
their side I mean the house right now
they're just following Paul's master
plan where do you think the game goes
from here
I think it's going to be very
predictable mark will go next and then
matter Raven and then the real heat
starts and there's a lot more where that
came from just had to ETL mine calm to
see my full interview with Julie and
tune in tonight for a special Friday
episode of Big Brother at 8:00 7:00
central on CBS so much big brother so
many hours of Big Brother that's better
that's better I love that our time has
come for our beloved new music Friday
playlist now we've got to kick off
today's jam sesh with this year's MTV
video Vanguard recipient pink the singer
is leading the resistance in the music
video for her new single what about us
[Music]
what about all the time
[Music]
I want to be in that video
now if Peaks message is resist then
Weezer's is persist the band is back
with a cute little end of summer Bop
chasing their summer love in Mexican
sender
[Music]
and finally Aly & AJ returned with their
first new single in a decade it could
not be more stoked to share take me with
fans as et found out when we sat down
with them back at comic-con we're
releasing our first single yeah after a
long time away from music we haven't
released anything under alien AJ in 10
years so we're really excited and this
um this single really represents any
sound and just past the bold artists and
it's been a long time
[Music]
it's very West Coast because we're
California girls but I it's funny when
we applied the music to our friends a
lot of them were we're saying that it's
very nostalgic sounding so I don't know
necessarily what yeah what that means
but I was like I like nostalgia so okay
but it's definitely aimed towards pop
and there's a little bit of any deep
influence there still definitely sounds
like Alan aging what we represent but so
there you have the folks it's time for
you to blast these jams over the weekend
and while you're at it hit subscribe and
then come back and join us Monday for a
new episode of the daily Denny as always
thank you for watching and be sure to
stick with ET online.com for all the
latest in the entertainment world bye